in the same way that kylo ren's ultra
high-waisted pants will never catch on
as the next hot fashion trend it's an
undeniable fact that not everyone loves
Star Wars the last Jedi
when the film launched in theaters in
December 2017 audiences were more
divided than Darth Maul now as we're
nearing the one-year anniversary of the
Rian Johnson directed flick an old
complaint about the last Jedi has
resurfaced but it's not just any old
gripe it's one that regards a plot hole
that one youtuber claims quote broke
Star Wars forever the scene in question
is the one in which Vice Admiral a mole
and whole toad does something no
character is ever attempted to do in the
history of Star Wars she kicks general
Leia Organa ship in the Lightspeed and
proceeds to drive it directly into
Supreme Leader Snoke ship the mega class
star dreadnought that served as the
first orders mobile headquarters
bulldoze move allowed the Rebel Alliance
members aboard the Radice a narrow
window of time to escape on the
lifeboats before the first order could
track the raddest through hyperspace
before this moment and the last Jedi
fans had never seen a Star Wars
character carry out a kamikaze attack
once they did well it got the gears in
their brains turning some franchise
loyals like youtuber Thor Skywalker
field at the scene ripped a hole in more
than the supremacy it opened up a plot
hole in the entire Star Wars universe
Thor Skywalker argues that a pull doe
could damage the supremacy by jumping to
Lightspeed and crashing into it the
rebels could have done the exact same
thing to the Death Star in a new hope he
further claims that the so called bull
doe maneuver renders the rebel alliances
attack on the Death Star somewhat
ineffective since it could have easily
created a battle station that could
implement the same tactic hold o used
one that also has quote the ability to
send or launch massive objects into
hyperspace at planets or whatever else
it might want to destroy in his argument
he stated why doesn't hold oh just put
some droids on some transport ships and
have them jumping into hyperspace at the
first order fleet she apparently knew
such an action would work so it doesn't
make sense why she waited so long to
employ it you can then go back to any
battle in Star Wars history and wonder
why the whole doe maneuver wasn't used
the last Jedi seems to be the most
reckless in terms of what it lets in to
the Canon it pulled apart or broke the
of Star Wars by introducing things that
makes us question everything that comes
before it we can certainly see where
these arguments are coming from in a new
hope the rebels probably could have done
what Holder did in the last Jedi but
would it have made the movie better nope
then man your ships and may the force be
with you
[Music]
yeah
while holders attack does signify a bit
of a logic question in the Star Wars
universe to call it a franchise breaking
plot hole is a little much to some fans
the holder maneuver truly has put an
irreversible dent in the series to
others it's not that big of a deal as
far as director Rian Johnson is
concerned the moment was actually
inspired by the original trilogy he
explained to the Empire film podcast
ever since hung is talking about how if
you don't get the calculations right you
could go through you know if I have to
always wanted to see with how it looked
like conflicting opinions about whether
or not the last Jedi broke Star Wars
aside writer director JJ Abrams could
still keep the franchise afloat with
episode 9 set for release on December
20th 2019 so what do you think did the
whole dough maneuver break Star Wars for
you let us know in the comments
[Music]